eosinophils are associated with allergic  response and anti-helmint response they  constitute the minority of the  circulating leukocytes they are  generated from the bone marrow myeloid  progenitor and eventually they move to  thymus or the GI tract histologically  eosinophils has bilobed nucleus and the  cytoplasm filled with cytotoxic granules  there are many surface receptors such as  pattern recognition receptors FC  receptors chemokine receptors addition  receptors cytokine receptors Etc there  are granules like primary and lipid  bodies there are specific proteins such  as major basic protein eosinophilication  protein eosinophil peroxidase and  eosinophil derived neurotoxin which are  playing multiple roles eosinophils kills  the parasites and that's the major  function there are many disease which  are associated with higher eosinophil  numbers like asthma like  chronic helmet infection or even  leukemias watch the full video to know  more